first one it's a flat right learn the
way that you know it's a flat rate light
it is because the question tells you he
takes a loan and it tells you it's a
flat interest rate okay so therefore
that tree gives in my mind simple
interest and that's why I've written it
over there on the left hand side for
myself what I know to substitute into
finding that interest charged well on
simple interest the formula itself it
will hand you simple interest rather it
will hand you the interest that's been
charged okay so you can see principal
rate number of time periods and so
there's your number okay you happy with
that find the total amount to be repaid
I was really pleased going around having
look I saw one people highlighting you
saw that that phrase means okay what I'm
gonna do is take what I worked out in
the previous part and add it to the
interests sorry added to the principal
Radha and that's the total known okay so
you've got your eleven for forty and
hopefully you saw the progression from
Part A to B and B the scene to find the
monthly repayment you had to work out
well how many months am I gonna have to
change to repay this theme is five years
so you can see how I got sixty months
well that's a division signs have been
um it's a bit small let me fix them if
you want to work out how much has to be
paid every single one of those sixty
months it's just the division okay so
$109 sixty-seven cents is what happens
after you round
okay any questions before I move on to
that is it look okay
yeah alright so that was a bit of a
warm-up even though it had played parts
it's only the next one now you've seen
these before
you've looked at a table like this and
it's a bit tricky to read which is the
whole point of asking a question like
this okay so read the beginning it says
the table below shows the payment per
$1,000 on a monthly reducible loan in
other words you know how we worked out
up here we worked out their monthly
payment on such and such amount of
borrowing etc so the table we're looking
at right now it does all those
calculation
for you and just says alright if you're
paying off a thousand dollars this is
your repayment well we're not paying off
thousand dollars we're paying off two
hundred and ninety thousand dollars do
you see
so therefore what I do is I say well
that's two hundred and ninety thousand
so 290 of those each one of those
calculator is wrong oh yeah sure I'd
probably give 1 mark attitude so and
this is one of the reasons why it's a
bit like this table doesn't make it as
absolutely obvious as it could the thing
that it's missing so I'll zoom back out
a second the thing that's missing is a
dollar sign here's the thing right there
are two reasons there are two reasons
you can no it's not a percentage okay
here's the first reason that's a
percentage right like it wouldn't really
make sense to say oh seven percent will
be 19.8% which one isn't okay so that
there's like that this is a percentage
tells you this is not a percentage and
then secondly just come back to the
first sentence in the question it says
the table below shows the payment per
$1,000 payment per $1,000 so that's
gonna be a dollar amount question if I
just puts the number wrong oh yeah I
think maybe I'm just right up to 6 4 7
four to six okay that's cool I just must
have not done something can you tell me
again to six for seven point two nine
four two nine four dot dot dot so now
I'm going to round done is that look bad
I'm sorry even the best of us press the
calculator always lands
all right so but you see the process you
see the principle on how I read the
table and then how I use that to say if
this is how much I have to pay for every
thousand dollars then there will be two
hundred ninety all those right let's
have a look at Bella show us the payment
her money got you guys on a monthly
reducible one okay all right number
three you can see hopefully again flat
rate one so again your brain trick is
simple interest so that's why I've
written over here the simple interest
formula but we're using it in a
different way to how we used a in
question one what's different in this
question you try and find the rate
earlier on we're trying to find the
interest as a dollar amount but here I'm
trying to find the interest as a rate as
a percentage so you can see right there
there's my unknown I don't know what R
is so I just leave it as are the rest of
it you can see this is what I got when I
multiplied 14,000 by two-and-a-half what
did I do can someone let me out what did
i do from y22 line three I divided by by
35,000 right because I'm trying to get
rid of it from off of the are it's
attached that I want to get
yes that's a very common error it's
really easy to say oh yeah we frequently
like if you see two numbers you think I
better divide these the most common
thing to do is divide the big number but
it's vulnerable yeah but here you're
after an interest rate which is a really
tiny number right so do you see I've got
this number and then I have converted it
to a percent you put it over there okay
so what you're gonna think about really
carefully and this is why I wrote it
over here on the right hand side it's
not easy right you've got to work out
what is what and where it belongs
okay so read the question carefully now
when it says a flat-rate load of $14,000
right so the word is $14,000 the thing
that belongs on the other side of the
equation is not the value of the line
it's the value of the interest right and
that's why it says at the beginning
let's change Pelikan 3275 interests so
that's fine and that's how you know it
belongs on the left hand side it was
yeah you're gonna use ing PRN all over
again but instead you'll know what I P
and AH you know what those values and
then Andy's having fun
correct so you can see my first line is
always every time no exceptions
take the formula and then just
substitute don't do any simplifying here
don't do any like ooh let's rearrange
try to save some time we generally would
just muck up and then lose time cuz
we're gonna go back and fix it make this
like literally be able to read off maybe
you want to copy that first line down
and on top of it say I P ah and you
should be able to read that off and say
that's the principle that's the number
of years that I've been there etc after
that this turns into an AM one question
right you remember when were just
solving equations under algebra so
that's what this becomes this one it
depends a little bit but the short
answer is maybe but I will say this line
if you guys made a mistake is that your
reading point if you made a mistake you
probably made it on that line most
people do not make their errors down
here so therefore if you get that line
right that means you understand
something and maybe just like I did on
the previous question
you've just pressed someone is wrong so
you have demonstrated understanding so
there's a good chance you get something
on that but I can't say for certain it
depends on the exam yeah yeah so this is
this is worth something it's just a
question of how much and it depends on